[Music]
foreign
there is an upcoming shock movie that
just came out of the blue so to say this
one is called the black demon and it is
due for release in April of this year it
will rival and compete in Terror against
another shock movie to make 2 the trench
which is also stated to be released
later this year in August so the premise
of the black demon movie goes as follows
a man named Paul Sturgis travels with
his family to Mexico to visit an oil rig
owned by his firm as they arrive he
finds the facility nearly deserted with
just a few fearful workers remaining who
informs him that the rig has been
frequently attacked by a gigantic shop
from a Mexican legend with the Rick
sinking and the shark hunting them he
must find a way to save his family and
stay alive
so according to Legend the black demon
is a Mexican myth that has been passed
down from generation to generation
according to reports from fishermen all
around Baja California it is a gigantic
black shark specimen that haunts the
waters in and around the dreaded Seas it
is said that thousands of fishermen have
died facing off with this bees yet their
remains have never been found it is also
said that the black demon is responsible
for the depths of hundreds of whales
discovered around the Pacific Ocean in
what seems to be an attack by this
massive Beast a genocide of whales in
certain occasions it has also been
reported and spotted allegedly in the
mar de Cortez which is also known as the
Bay of California
as a Cryptid the black demon is claimed
to be between 6 meters or 20 feet long
which is the size of a large great white
shark and also up to 18 meters or 60
feet which is pretty close to that of a
Megalodon it was also estimated to weigh
between 28 to 45 tons it is supposed to
look like a great white shark but with a
very black coloration and a very long
tail others speculate that it may be a
megalodon or a new species of shark or a
descendant of Megalodon are also just an
extraordinarily enormous great white
many Expeditions were launched to
relocate the creature even on Monster
Quest a reality show that investigates
cryptids in the chapter called Mega Jaws
but sadly no conclusive results were
found and it still remains a mystery so
going back to the movie in the trailer
it seems that the characters visit an
oil rig and was dumbfounded when they
find out many missing crewmen and the
surviving ones tell them of a curse and
a Wrath of nature that has manifested
into a giant shark in the many scenes of
the trailer we actually see get to see
the really massive shot that was around
the size of a Megalodon around 60 feet
or more it seems to be on a vengeful
quest to finish off the people in the
oil rig as soon as they fall into the
sea the black demon also wants to sing
the oil rig however it more resembles a
great white in appearance than a
Megalodon although it also had traits
similar to the Meg such as the gigantic
mouth and a couple of rows of serrated
teeth the Megalodon however was a shark
species that went extinct about 3.6
million years ago the Meg is recognized
as one of the biggest and most powerful
predators to have ever lived in the
oceans although its appearance and
maximum size is still unknown due to
fragmented remains experts disagree on
whether it would have looked more like a
stockier variant of a great white shark
or even like a whale shark or a basking
shark or even like a sand tiger shark
the most current estimate with the
narrowest error range implies a maximum
length of 20.3 meters or 67 feet in real
life the mech unlike the black demon was
a real animal but it went extinct
millions of years ago before humans even
evolved as a sophisticated species
in the movie however the Meg the shark
species survived deep within the
Mariana's Trench within a thermocline
layer that separated the underwater
ecosystem from the outside ocean there
were a couple of Megalodon sharks that
escaped following the discovery of that
ecosystem and The Exodus of the
submersible from that place after a
shark attack the first Megalodon that
was captured was 45 feet or 13.7 meters
long while the second and larger one was
double the size and even consumed the
body of the first one after it was
caught the second Megalodon was easily
around 80 to 90 feet or 24 to 27 meters
in length and far larger than the black
demon seen in the movie trailer
so in this year's sequel the mech II the
trench the most probable story would be
the growth development and shock attacks
of the young baby Megalodon and that
survived the parents death in the first
movie but seeing a baby Meg the size of
a normal great white would not be so
terrifying therefore we predict that the
setting would be around 10 years after
the events of the first Meg and that the
second one the juvenile would have by
that time grown into an adult rivaling
the size of a baron so the proper
comparison between these two gigantic
sharks will be better showcased after
the movies are released but as to how
the black demon in the trailer is seen
against the first Mech from the first
movie it would seem that the Meg is
still far larger and more powerful but
who knows if the other one might
actually be Supernatural in Origins and
therefore be more ruthless and more
deadly than a Megalodon and also with
extra abilities
so I hope you have enjoyed watching this
video do hit that like button for
support and subscribe but most of all
smash that Bell icon for regular updates
on new videos right here on this channel
till the next one take care fam